happy glorious Monday to everyone here
so what happens when you're running out
of white racists
oh is it even meant to be funny
oh that was great that's never happened
before the setup gets a joke well when
you run out of white races like Doritos
you gotta make more
that means it's time for
[Music]
this guy blows brought to you by
sugar-free candy ruining Halloween since
1962. I don't think I don't think that's
real yep Charles blow is the worst
writer in America it's either him or the
guy who keeps riding dwarf on my office
door
Tyrus but blow whose name is short for
blowing smoke up his own ass
takes a tail involving Latino leaders in
La making bigoted remarks about blacks
and calls it proof of white supremacy
yeah so Latina smears a black person but
that's white racism making white
supremacy look more diverse than a 1980s
Benetton ad remember those he calls it
light Supremacy which copies white
supremacy because when a brown skinned
minority says something anti-black they
obviously cribed it from the whites so I
guess you can judge how racist someone
is by the sunblock number they use the
higher the number the more chance you
have of being racist I use a 45.
so basically I'm a grand wizard
it's racism light half the pigment and
all the calories
of course non-whites can be bigoted from
Louis Farrakhan to Joy Reed but that's
not what blow is saying he's saying that
there are different levels of pigment
power and the lighter ones are what he
calls white adjacent which sounds like
sherwin-williams's newest color
that paint store cat
anyway but when these bigots insult
blacks they learn such bad behavior of
course from the whites
but isn't that belief racist in itself
that Latinos aren't smart enough to be
racist on their own they had to copy
Whitey
and I guess blow never assumed that's
assumed that such Behavior could have
been learned from him this guy plays the
race card more than Liz Warren trying to
get it to Harvard
so okay now even brown people are white
supremacists lighter becomes wider when
Brown scoffs at black the Crayola
crayons research Department must be
pulling their hair out
and consider poor Larry Elder who was
once smeared as the face of white
supremacy he's thinking damn another job
taken from a black man
tough break Larry even relief Factor
can't ease that pain
[Applause]
great product by the way but while blow
claims to condemn racial tribalism he
then does the same thing seeking a new
racial team sport and dividing the teams
based on Darkness instead of shirts
against skins it skins against darker
skins now if we follow a blow it's as if
whiteness itself is an evil substance
and there are gradients gradients of it
that contribute to racism but maybe it's
time that we replace the word racism
with whiteness and save everyone the
time you know in the bad old days being
white major racists now being racist
makes you white even if you're brown or
white light I wonder how they feel if
blow came up to them and said what's up
lady
true if this guy saw a black squirrel
being attacked by a gray squirrel he
would say the gray squirrel learned that
from the white people
who knew white supremacists were so lazy
one minute they're marching with tiki
torches now they're Outsourcing their
racism to immigrants
finally blow ties us all to the wish to
defund police the most disastrous
anti-black policy since they canceled
the Jeffersons
it's true if you don't support the
funding then you're racist against
blacks there's not much wiggle room
there blow so shallow he should wear no
diving sign around his neck
but we know a decline in policing hurts
blacks more than any policy of the last
30 years also black people want more
police and look at the skin color of the
Dead since the crime wave exploded
they're mostly black but blow only sees
pigment among the living because the
dead don't respond to his click bait so
what's this all come down to well
Charles's own it's his own racist meal
ticket you really gotta hate white
people to concoct this kind of feverish
hate dream and also you got to see it as
your career blow is a one-trick pony
trying to survive in the media landscape
you can't ever say racism has diminished
because if he says that he will be out
of a race-baiting job so no wonder he's
expanding the dating pool of bigotry
he's like a horny dude changing his
Tinder radius from 10 miles to planet
Earth
who hasn't done that
plus he knows his employer can't ever
fire him right that's racist he'll say
he's learned well over the years
watching Hall of Fame race baiters from
Sharpton to Sean King to Joy Reed you
need to expand the accusatory net of
racism even if it means that you're
saying all the hard work of civil rights
leaders of the past 60 years made things
worse it's so odd that people like blow
are called progress aggressives because
for them nothing ever progresses it just
gets worse
in his tiny little mind it's still 1958
and really that blows
what
tonight's guests
people think it's cologne but he's
actually stinking Rich most of making
money on Fox Business Charles Payne
she's like a Vespa Italian and goes too
fast for a normal conversation
outnumbered co-host Emily cabano all
right
she's like a fresh sheet of paper White
Blank and ready to cut you Fox News
contributor cat two
and Sleeping Dogs let him lie my massive
sidekick in the NWA World Television
Champion Tyrus
Charles as always you look fantastic
well thank you very much yes amazing tie
and jacket Ensemble and I like the
little uh handkerchief too that's a nice
touch thank you it's whimsical it is
Whimsical you bring a smile to my face
do you think I'm this is an obvious
question when somebody is constantly
labeling everybody as racist the people
who are off the hook are the real
racists you know like Brian Kilmeade
yeah yeah
you know it's it's I mean you hit it
right on the head for a lot of these
folks it's about money and power
I remember the day after President Obama
was elected the NAACP sent out a bunch
of emails saying it's going to get worse
now
this major milestone
but if you take away this what do they
have what power source do they have and
it's unfortunate because when there is a
real issue of racism it's like well you
know what the hell you don't want
Charles blow listen according to the New
York Times covid-19 was racist yeah
climate change is racist like I'm like
golly it's tough being a brother in
America because like everything is right
is right I mean if it rains it's racist
if it you know everything is against me
but it's not me I'm worried about it's
the kids who have to grow up in this
sort of environment and as a little
black kid you always get the messages
never stop starting from the very top
every time President Biden speaks to
black people it's about they're coming
to get you and then someone like Charles
blow Echoes that and it's really a shame
yeah there was some poll that found that
people thought that we were less racist
30 years ago than we are now which means
that even though we've made race the
central focus of so many things it only
made things worse Emily and I blame you
for that
I haven't been around that long yes I
agree with you and I'll add on to the
statement of they're coming to get you
and so this is how you should think and
this is how you should vote and this is
how you should feel and that is the
message only we can protect you only we
care about you uh and you know of course
the exchange is the it's true you'll get
trinkets we'll give you some trinkets
for your protection and your vote I love
trinkets
from swag but you're right because then
then that recipient is beholden right to
the person who's the Faustian deal
that's right um and I see that too with
this which is remember when everything
was about Latin X or latinx right and
then all of a sudden only three percent
of his Hispanic Americans actually
identified or wanted that we know now
that almost 7 out of ten Hispanic
Americans are voting toward or prefer
the GOP or conservative ideals so maybe
perhaps the Democrat Party the
progressive left is seen is that is that
a lost group is that a loss of monolith
that they wanted to shove in a box that
they wanted them to vote a certain way
and since they've lost them perhaps oh
now fine you're just white supremacist
is that the narrative that's an
interesting point if they're like saying
screw you you're just like everybody
else like we're going to cut our losses
Tyrus how lucky am I that now we got
other racists
so tired I'm so tired of being the face
yeah you know it's like you know it's
always a lot of Firsts you know and uh
here I am sitting in this chair
about to defend white supremacist
like they didn't work hard for
generations to keep their gene pool
going this way to have someone just take
it all away from just give it to
somebody else yes they're stealing white
supremacists Jay gave up success and
education to invest in trailer homes for
a reason and you're not just gonna take
it away from them you know it drives me
crazy because we just can't say hey
those uh
they were talking bad about brothers
just happened to be Latino the bigger
reason is they're just yes I'm saying
like every group is not above having
someone you wish wasn't in your group
amen white people
so
when that group acts up if if blow had
any backbone he would have had the guts
to attack the individual but that's not
what the woke do they create individuals
in the facade it's a group so this one
or two or individuals said something
about hey we're used to it we're we used
to be the backbone for everyone's
complaint when we just keep winning
that's what we do but instead of having
to you make the group so it's the whole
thing and now you guys get to taste
because back when I was growing up 30
years ago it was worse yeah yeah
whenever something bad happened in the
news I'd be like this please don't be a
brother yeah please don't be a brother
because I had a residual effect where
everyone would blame all of us for this
the sins of one and they're trying to do
that now yeah when they try to blame one
oh that one person in the rest of the
world is good saying no
that gut feels wrong but for them it's
more comfortable to say all white people
are wrong because then they can create
that horrible article that I read about
half of it before I said you know what
I'm Dumber for this yeah exactly and
that's what it was it was about a column
you know Kat you'd say the same thing to
me it's like you just get so angry when
a skinny white girl does something
really bad
you go like oh God another woman
throwing a bottle on a plane because
they
they always let my dog sit
I think I actually completely understand
how and why he wrote this I think it was
I don't think he was dying to write
about this I think he knew he had to
write about something
we've all been there yeah you didn't
know what to write about he's like all
right there's this Mexican school board
members that are kind of racist so I'll
write this whole thing about how they're
really racist and it doesn't mean it
represents everybody but I can still
write about how maybe it could yeah and
then he's done obviously it's it's
harmful and it's dumb but I think that's
probably what happened because it makes
no sense I mean at the very top he says
he's not saying when he goes on to sort
of say the whole rest of the time he
writes a whole article about white
supremacy without mentioning a single
white person yeah that's incredible well
your New York Times amplifies it that's
the other thing this could have been
some guy that just put that on his
Instagram but instead the New York Times
consistently gives him a huge platform
when he repeats himself all the time
because it's always the same outrageous
claims that it's all about skin color
Yes they share the same talking points
it's the narrative so it doesn't matter
what it means as long as he says the
right thing
why supremacists the rest of us are
struggling and he's the only one who can
save us there you go
all in a nice little package much like
me
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else